[Music]
hey come on buddy
oh that's a big one there you go
well guys it's another saturday and
another project i'm planning on doing
another video with my hand cart i don't
know if you guys remember i built this
thing back in early 2020 and did a video
on it it's been sitting under a tarp for
about a year and a half now so
pulled it out and uh a lot of water
damage so i'm gonna clean out the garage
here a little bit pull this thing in and
see what we can do to repair it
you know we'll just kind of go from
there
[Music]
all the plywood's delaminating
the windows busted out the door here is
really rotted you can see how much bend
is in it it is so soft right there yeah
it looks like the plywood on this thing
is absolute mush but we're gonna try to
get it all back in working order
and uh to do so we're gonna have to
really take this thing apart
[Applause]
oh you can see how bad the delamination
is
[Music]
[Music]
all right guys i got it all disassembled
now i need to just go to the hardware
store and get some more plywood
oh you can't take the car i'm taking the
kids to the doctor
oh
like right now okay all right we're
going to the doctors
[Music]
[Applause]
do you want to do that again no no
you guys feeling better
yes
everybody out i'm going to the hardware
store
very careful with it
[Music]
[Music]
well it's too cold to paint outside so
we brought this project into the garage
[Music]
well this was a lot more work that i was
expecting but i got a lot more work done
today than i was expecting so
ah we'll pick this up again tomorrow
morning
all right it's another beautiful day in
the garage
[ __ ]
[Music]
so
so
[Applause]
[Music]
well it's a beautifully cold winter day
here and i think it's time to load up
the hand cart and go camping with jacob
all right hop in all right jacob you
ready
all right buddy we're here
there you go
welcome to the cno canal trail it's a
185 mile trail that goes along the
potomac river and a series of canals and
locks that were used for shipping goods
from the capitol all the way to
cumberland maryland you can see through
the woods that's the potomac river and
over here to the right this is where the
canal used to be this used to be full of
water and long boats full of goods would
be towed by horse and mule upstream this
is all national park now and this tow
path that the horses used to walk is now
an amazing biking and hiking trail and
we are gonna hike that trail and do some
camping and check out all the historical
stuff along the way this is gonna be fun
check it out this is one of the locks
the canal system isn't like a river it's
more like a staircase and each time
they'd go up a step they'd need a lock
and this right here is lock number 31.
so the canal on this side of the lock is
at a lower elevation than at this side
of the lock and a boat would sail in to
the lock
they would flood it the boat would rise
up and then they'd open this door and it
would sail out slightly higher hey jake
you warm
good
it's about 39 degrees right now so it's
it's a little nippy and it's good to be
walking get the blood flowing
check it out there's the potomac river
and there's a little creek flowing down
the hill into the potomac every time the
canal needed to cross a creek they
needed to build an aqueduct so the boats
could sail over those creeks and that
stone footing is what's left over the
old aqua duck
look at this crazy tree here
what that's a cool tree
so check out is the upper potomac river
come back here and camp
yeah that's probably not a bad idea
winner camping and hiking is the best if
you don't like bugs crowds and humidity
get out and do this stuff in the winter
time
it's
you nice check this out we got this is
stinging nettle okay if you've ever
rubbed into this you've given you a bit
of a rash but you can pick the leaves by
grabbing it from the top and plucking it
and then if you boil the leaves it gets
rid of all the little nettles and it
actually tastes like boiled spinach it's
a good edible plant you can see it's one
of the only greens still out here in the
woods in the middle of wintertime but
make sure you know what you're doing
before you eat anything these right here
these are poison ivy berries i've never
met an edible white berry that you want
to eat so if you see a white berry leave
it alone unless you really know what
you're doing
here's another one of the locks
hey check it out
little spot where a squirrel's been
eating walnuts must mean there's a black
walnut tree around here somewhere it's
another good food source in the
wintertime
oh look i can see harper's ferry
well here we are at the crossroads of
the appalachian trail and the cno canal
trail you head over that bridge you
gotta get you to harpers ferry and down
the appalachian trail or you head north
along the c o canal trail this way
went ahead and stashed the cart in one
of these locks me and jake are gonna go
exploring a little bit
[Music]
yeah look there's even more up here
there's a fence along the send river in
paris where young couples will put
padlocks as a symbol of their love
and i'm guessing people are doing
something similar here because there are
padlocks everywhere
rivers crystal clear so this is where
the shenandoah river dumps into the
potomac
and that right there is harper's ferry
it's a very historic town a lot of
importance and history from the civil
war
there you go
this spot is almost smack dab in the
middle of the appalachian trail which
runs from georgia all the way up to
maine
one of the things harper's ferry is most
famous for is john brown's revolt john
brown was a militant abolitionist who
believed he was going to free the slaves
by force and violence so he brought a
bunch of guns and a few men here to
harpers ferry and tried to take over the
town and start a slave uprising it
didn't go well and he ended up holding
up in this building right here and where
the u.s military went and fared him out
and they ended up executing him there
was a popular song called john brown's
body that was about hanging john brown
and that tune from that song was used
for battle hem of the republic a good
chunk of harper's ferry is run by the
national park service and so there's
tons of little historic merchant shops i
think there's a blacksmithing shop let's
see if this place is over
okay which one do you want
okay
here you want me to open it up for you
but don't let it now
i don't think it's gonna melt i don't
think we have to worry about that
that's a boy that loves his ice cream
well it's getting late and it's getting
a little cold and we still have several
miles to do before we get to our
campground so i think we better get back
to the cart
the wind's picking up and the
temperatures drop and i can feel it
you're gonna take little kids camping in
cold weather invest in a good sleeping
bag
how does that feel is that warm
all right good
i think jacob's falling asleep on me
oh yeah jacob's out
the canal we're following was man-made
so in order to get water in it they
needed inlet locks locks or gates that
connected the canals to the potomac
river so they could get water in and out
this was one of those inlet locks they
just opened the gates
and water from the potomac river would
flood into the canal i keep having to
remind myself that all 185 miles of this
canal were dug by hand and with men
using their backs and chisels and
hammers
over there's the ruins of one of the
lock keeper houses
i think we're pretty close to our
campsite which is a good thing because
sun just disappeared over the hill
well jacob still asleep so i'm gonna go
ahead and get the fire going
[Music]
little zips fire starters here
we're gonna lose our light pretty quick
so we're gonna get this cart transformed
into a bunk bed
[Music]
so
really correct
well there we go that's our shelter for
tonight sleeping space down here
and
sleeping space up here this little
bottom space can get kind of breezy at
night so i can go and
raise this up just a little bit
to block out the wind well both of us
have those negative 25 bags from
feathered friends so i don't think we're
going to be cold at all tonight but i
think it's time to wake jacob up
hey jacob
wake up ed
okay just come on down here there's just
there's your bags in there
you cozy in here jacob
you like this
good okay listen i'll go make you some
dinner okay when it's dinner time i'll
get you okay
okay
i asked jacob what he wanted to eat and
he said mre
it's gonna put you on this this will get
you higher up and keep your bottom
warmer
should have an army spoon to eat this
there you go
lucky charms marshmallows
i think you could eat those if you
wanted
right here
you nice and warm in there
it's late and i'm tired so i'm going to
zip up this bag and go to sleep i'll
talk to you guys in the morning
good morning
i do not want to get out of my bag
i got a bag of bread flour and i've put
a little bit of yeast in here a pinch of
sugar pinch of salt and a little bit of
cinnamon
you see how i try to stretch it and it
just breaks
when i've done it right it'll be able to
stretch like play-doh i've been kneading
it and adding a little water to it for
the last 10 minutes
you can see
it's a lot
stretchier the east has got to stay warm
to rise so
i'm going to tuck it right there while
i'm waiting for that bread to rise and
we get the fire started and you know
straighten up a few other things
somebody's awake good morning
hey
hi guys
all right bread looks good it's expanded
about twice its size and it's still nice
and warm
hey jake you want some of this
here you want some honey butter
that's a little honey bottle there's a
little bit of honey butter
no that'll go
mm-hmm
is this cozy yeah all right let's let's
go get see mama
it's just a beautiful day to be out my
son
i'm enjoying this
[Music]
[Music]
there we are this
[Music]
jacob did you have a good time
i hope you guys enjoyed watching this as
much as we enjoyed filming it if you
guys want to see more adventures from
the outdoor boys youtube channel don't
forget to
click subscribe
we put out new adventures every saturday
morning
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]